In machine learning, one of the best ways to learn
more about your data is by classifying it with
what you already know. You can group together a
bunch of data based on similar characteristics.
Because you already know these characteristics,
you can classify the data using
supervised machine learning.
A very common supervised machine
learning algorithm for multiclass
classification is k-Nearest Neighbor. This is
an instance-based machine learning algorithm,
or what's also called lazy
learning. With lazy learning,
the bulk of the computation happens right
before you want to classify your data.
The learning doesn't happen continuously. Instead,
you run all your computation in one big instance.
In a sense, you're saving up all your energy
for one big splash. k-NN compares something
you don't know to what you already have. So, in
some ways, you're getting immediately rewarded
for the size and quality of your training
data. The downside is that this takes a
lot of computational power, so sometimes it's
difficult to use k-NN on very large data sets.
Think of it this way. For a veterinary doctor, one
of the most difficult jobs was trying to classify
the breed of each new dog. There are hundreds
of different known dog breeds. Not only that,
the dogs aren't that close-minded about who they
breed with, so you have a lot of mixed breeds.
Each time when there is a new dog, the veterinary
doctor would hold it up to several of the existing
dogs that were already classified. Then
we'd look at some of the characteristics.
Maybe it was the shape of their face
or the color of their hair. In a sense,
the purpose was trying to classify the unknown
dog by looking for its nearest neighbor.
Another way to look at it is you're
trying to minimize the distance between
the unknown dog and the known breeds. If
the characteristics were closely matched,
then there was a very short distance between
the unknown dog and its nearest neighbor.
Minimizing the distance is a key part of
k-Nearest Neighbor. The closer you are to
your nearest neighbors, the more likely you
are to be accurate. The most common way to do
this is through something called Euclidean
distance. There is a pretty sophisticated
mathematical formula that can help see the
distance between your different data points.
Now, imagine you had millions of dogs and you
wanted to classify them based on their breed.
To start out, we might want to create two key
characteristics. These will help you classify
dogs that share the same breed. These are often
called predictors. So, let's use their weight and
the length of their hair. Now let's take these
two characteristics and put them on an X-Y axis
diagram. Let's put the length of their hair along
the Y-axis and their weight along the X-axis.
Let's take 1,000 classified dogs in our training
set. We'll put them on the graph based on their
weight and hair length. Now let's take our
unknown dog and put it in the same chart.
You can see that it's not matched with another
dog, but it has a bunch of close neighbors.
Let's say we use a K of five. That means we'd
want to put a circle around our unclassified
dog and its five closest neighbors. You can see
that if the distance of the other dogs is shorter,
you'll probably get a much
more accurate classification.
Now let's look at the five closest neighbors.
You'll see that three of them are Huskies and
two of them are Shepherds You can be somewhat
confident to classify your unknown dog as a Husky.
k-Nearest Neighbor is a very common and
powerful machine learning algorithm.
That's because it can do more
than just sort dogs. In fact,
it's commonly used in finance to look for the
best stocks and even predict future performance.